you know we kind of brought up
religion and joseph campbell and myth
and the the propagation of ideas
and kind of before i forget i wanted to
ask your thoughts about this
you know jordan peterson i haven't
really
understood exactly like be able to pin
him down exactly
what he sees as the role of religion
in human society but it uh feels like
he's describing it as having
uh value for us this the ideas of myth
are valuable there are valuable
mechanisms
toward i think you mentioned kind of
directing us
in this world as a human society
do you think about myth do you think
about religion what's the use of it in
the in this construct of
markets and this uh in this framework of
um
where ideas are ultimately the
the fundamental thing that makes
societies work
yeah i think jordan peterson who i'm
a huge fan of he's been very influential
in my thinking
and influential on my own religious
views as well
i think his position would be
and he's said this before that he
acts as if god exists and
i've had some some arguments about this
before but to me that points towards
the preeminence of action and how
important action is versus
your your cognitive beliefs necessarily
um and i think there is a lot of utility
in that that if you
follow the moral code of something like
the bible
um you do reap benefits from that
society reaps benefits from that
um and this is not and sometimes i bring
up this point and people are like oh my
god are you kidding me have you read the
old testament they're
clobbering people with rocks when they
do the wrong thing it
the bible doesn't claim to be this like
do everything that was done in the bible
it's more like charting this moral
progression
where we came from this very barbaric
society into something
more like the new testament where we're
honoring you know individual sovereignty
above the state and things like that so
i think that
mythology itself is another form of data
compression
if you look at these stories you know
cain and abel is a good example
or peterson makes the point that it's a
tiny story it's you know a paragraph
ish long but it contains so many layers
of meaning
um in regards to violence evil betrayal
work um the divergence between intention
and result
you know because i think cain is
actually making
uh he's making the effort to sacrifice
for god but the sacrifices he's making
are not
god doesn't find them useful right and
so he sort of rejects
rejects them for a
again if we're we're organized by these
useful fictions right these these
uh hierarian imagined orders i think
mythology is kind of the original
version of that
where we were learning to organize
ourselves
around stories to best
coordinate our action across space and
time
and so i think it's very foundational
um and back to what we were saying in
the beginning that if value truly is
fundamental
i think it's interesting that all these
stories point towards
often common moral values they're not
perfectly aligned
but it does speak to just the the
evolutionary
importance of morality and the
subjectivity of morality where morality
sort of
evolves over time based on
you know frankly the capital stock we've
accumulated the more capital stock we've
accumulated
the easier life is the less barbaric we
have to be
whereas if we're living in conditions of
true scarcity
then we tend to be a bit more barbaric
towards one another
you